what is going on everybody and welcome
to another generative
python transformers video in this video
we're gonna be doing is building our
data set now with all machine learning
when you're building a data set
uh to train a model you have to be
thinking okay what is my input what is
my output
with the hugging face transformers
library that we're going to use to train
this model
uh there is a little bit that gets
abstracted away for you
but you still probably want to be
thinking about this so
so with uh there's kind of two major
styles of transformers you've got the
open ai's gpt which is generative
pre-trained transformer
and then you've got the bert style model
which is
bi-directional encoder representation
transformers something like that the the
verbiage is slightly different but
that's what the letters stand for
the big difference here is the burp
model is bi-directional
and the open ai gpt model i think the
right word for this is like auto
regressive but essentially it goes
linearly
so in order to come up with you know
some token
the gpt model only looks at tokens
previous to it so
tokens are just rep or like numerical
representations of
words or sub words or even individual
characters
in our case we're going to have it be a
sub word kind of bite-pairing coding
model but anyway it's only going to be
looking at the history of let's say if
we're thinking about it in
in human terms it's only if you know to
come up with the next token it's only
going to look at
the previous words that led up to that
point whereas the burp model
it's looking at previous words it's
looking at future words
so the burp model kind of fills in the
gaps so to speak
the the gpt model kind of generates
new um new stuff now you could use the
burp model for
generation um and it can do that so like
the burp model for example could take a
you know an article of text and then
make and generate a summary
the gpt model can could do the same
thing um
the the burp model can read a bunch of
text and then do question and answer
and the gpt model can sort of do the
same thing
so they both can do the same thing but
for sure the gpt model
generates like strings of data better
but for programming
you might you might um kind of both are
useful
so anyway i played i plan to play with
both and for us
the data set that is going to be
training these models is basically going
to be the same and that's going to be a
line by line
data set um uh and i think
in terms of describing some of the
changes that we're gonna make uh to
these python files i think we'll just
start coding
and then and i'll explain them as we get
to them so um i really think there's
like one meter change
so so anyway um i'm going to take uh
some of the code from part
two uh like our imports we're going to
take
os uh the curtsies formatting if you're
not on ubuntu i don't think this or
linux i don't think this works so you
just don't use
it when we use it and then finally
we once again will be iterating uh
through directories
we'll just have this over cool okay
so the first thing we want to do is we
have all these python files
but each file ideally will be
um some let me get rid of this before i
gets in my way uh each file is going to
have
um you know a variety of length
okay and our model is
we might use gpt2 which i i could have
this wrong
i think it's a 1024 um
maximum length of tokens we can also
change that especially because i think
to start we're gonna
we're gonna train this model from
scratch but again the p
in gpt stands for pre-trained and the
idea is true for both of
the gpt model and the burp model the
idea is you
pre-train the model on a very on like
the burp model is just fill in the blank
the gpt model is trained by you know
trying to predict the next token from a
string
the both of these models the idea is you
pre-train them on that very simple task
and then you can fine-tune them to do
all kinds of
just crazy tasks so um or you could just
continue to generate or fill in the
blank if that's what you want but
the step one is to train it step two is
j
generally to fine tune it on something
so um so yeah so what we want to do is
we want to specify
some sort of maximum length and i think
what we're going to say
for now and i'm going to call this car
length
because so far we've not created a
tokenizer so we actually
aren't we have no idea what will be the
the full token length of these uh
these files we can only guess right now
and so what we're going to go on is is
character length
and then what we'll do is
uh max car length we'll say
min car length and again uh making this
file
i uh let's go with 400. um making this
and like testing this and then building
a tokenizer and then testing the
tokenizer
uh to see what are the lengths because
ideally so if our models
maximum context is say 512 tokens
then we'd ideally like our samples to be
as many as possible as close as possible
to 512. now some files aren't even going
to have that much
but yeah so first we're going to base
this off of characters only
so you know again when you tokenize
since we're going to use byte parent
coding it's going to be kind of these
sub words so it'll be like der path or
d or d i and then r and then path might
be to
so this might be three tokens this might
be two tokens or
what we're gonna do is we're just gonna
go character by character we're just
gonna count the characters that way we
never have
more tokens than we're allowed to have
i wanna say if you had more it would
trim the top but i
i just can't remember so anyway uh
we we can we can work on this more once
we have our toke a tokenizer made
from a data set and then we can kind of
tweak it from there because again
the tokenization is really fast making
the data set is pretty fast i mean going
through
100 gigs of data is going to probably
take a while but
from what i've seen from the uh
tokenizer from hugging face
it's it's fast so we can we can fix this
more later but for now we'll use these
numbers
so the next thing is uh we want to read
each of these files and then we want to
know um
our dirt path full path um first off
let's go ahead
full paths we'll just make that an empty
list and then we'll say
full path uh full paths dot append
uh full path full path
and let's see
print lem uh full paths
uh this will just tell us how long does
it take uh
uh we don't need to use t for some
reason someone will point out before
this video is up but someone will
hopefully point out why
um oh this one
this is the the downside of uh copy and
pasting anyway someone will probably
point out what i did wrong with tqdm
what else let's see if we've screwed up
anything else i don't i think we'll be
okay
i thought this would go pretty quick
this isn't a big data set there we go
so in this case we've got 39 000 files
and what we're going to start with is
512. again i think the gp2t
default is 1024 for the context line i
got
again it's kind of irrelevant at this
stage especially because the first thing
i'm going to do
is train it from scratch i have tinkered
with some of the the baseline
models and i they're good but they're
not like
i don't know like gp22 is pretty good
and i know it's been trained for longer
than i'll even be able to train it on
like something like that
crazy station there but i think training
it from scratch will yield
just as good if not better results
anyway so
so now that we have our full paths um
a part of me wants to like pickle the
full path so i don't have to go through
this over and over
but uh we'll we'll we'll see what we can
do
and not pickle them so uh so the next
thing is we want to open each of these
files
so um for uh
file fpath in
full paths what do we want to do so
first off we want to read in this data
so we're going to say
data equals
open full path and
we want to read
cool uh let's go ahead and
print and
we'll break and then the other thing i
want to do
is open this we'll come over here
three mach data okay so we'll let that
run
um so what do we want to do so the first
thing we want to do is we want to get
the length of this data and see is it of
a decent um is it within our constraints
at the moment
uh uh
okay so this is the entire file
apparently um
so it is indeed python code
what is this anyway
okay uh continuing on so uh the first
question will be uh let's see so
uh if len
i can't use my arrow keys correct today
apparently if len d
uh is greater than
um so if it's the full file we're not
going to require it
to be uh 400 but we want it to be more
that like some files will be like
uh like for example you have a lot of
empty init files
right like dunder in its uh we don't
want that
i'm trying to think of what else we
might have um i don't i don't really
know i'm just to throw in a number 15
just be more than 15 characters and
we're happy with you
uh and then it needs to be less than or
equal to
the max character length if that is the
case
uh let's print um
print d uh and then we'll break
uh don't print this one
uh we'll rerun that while that's running
we'll continue working
so the first thing we need to do is we
need to get this all on one line so
again this is unacceptable it's got new
lines
and if like it literally has new line
characters and we could pass
like a backslash n to the model and it
probably would learn but the problem is
there's so much other python code
dealing with the encoding and decoding
if you pass a backslash n chances are
it's going to add another backslash to
the end
and as you continue going back and forth
and coding and decoding
my best guess is you're going to start
with a backslash end and you're going to
end
with like four or eight backslashes when
you get done
so this is going to be escaping these
escape characters and that's just no
good
so um so instead what we want to do is
we want to just
find and replace a new line character
with some other new
new line character so what we're going
to say is new line
character and we're just going to
something hopefully short
so we're going to do this this is going
to be our new new line character
now let's come in here okay so this is
an example of
a file that is within our limits makes
sense
cool that's such a basic thing we might
even want to like
this is a good example of maybe not good
enough
you know maybe i'm not even sure i
wonder what the length of that actually
is
um print d let's go ahead and print
uh print len d
and uh we'll go ahead and save that
come back over here let's go ahead and
run that one more time
move this over um and then let's go
ahead
let's do print d uh let's say let's say
uh fd so formatted data is equal to d
dot
replace and what we're going to replace
is all new line characters with whatever
we set as the new line character
so apparently that's 90. i think we want
more than 90.
i don't know um
we'll see let's see what we wind up with
we'll just go ahead and run that
um so we know lend full paths we already
know we had
like so we know we have 39 000 let's
just see like how much we end up losing
because we'll have
you'll see in a second we'll wind up
with more oh wait
one one way we're going to toss data
another way we're going to
uh let's make it a hundred um
we're gonna make more from one file so
let's go ahead and run that again
and did we print that no we didn't let's
just break that real quick i want to
print that out while we
print fd
probably should use colors um okay so
while that's running
uh what do we want to do now so now we
have
that is done so that's one way that we
will
um if this okay so that's one way we'll
do stuff so here
is the kind of new line fixed example
uh so that's one way that we will take
samples but many files are going to be
much much larger than this and we want
to be able to handle for those as well
so
the next thing is else
so if it is not within these bounds
then what we're going to try to do is uh
do some separations to attempt to make
it within those bounds so
uh the let's see we've got d so
[Music]
let's do um
trying to think of how i want to do this
probably a
double we would split by so you've got
this triple new line
or a double new line i we could split by
triple
new line but my fear is that we're not
going to get uh
that many i think we should split by
double new line but then if we only do
that we're gonna wind up with slices
within you know classes and stuff like
that
like a really good split would be like
by
double new line and uh some sort of
white space
d indentation but um
i'm just not smart enough for that
unfortunately i don't really feel like
doing that right now
we really just want to see does it work
and again you can always go back and
change this kind of like this won't be
too hard to go back and fix
so um i think what we'll do
is we'll say uh
[Music]
sd for split data is equal to
d dot split by um
let's see so we haven't replaced
anything yet so let's go ahead
and
i can't decide if i really actually want
to like switch this put this up here
because we're going to do that every
single time
like we're going to do this replace
operation
oh deal with that later okay split by
double new line i think
and then what we want to do is probably
um we'll stay
sub string equals
uh empty whoops and let us
uh so no longer do i really i don't
really want to do this part anymore
else uh if
uh let's just pass for now let's not
forget to do that though
uh and we'll do this this
this we don't want to break anymore and
in fact
probably what we'll do maybe we won't
pass here and instead what we'll do
is we'll actually just start building
the data set so um
with open um
and uh
what should we call this um
with open uh we'll append
as f i'm not sure what i want to call
this file
um
i don't know python code text
dot text that'll do for now uh okay so
with open that we're gonna iterate
and if this was the case we replaced by
newline character
and we'll just write that to the file so
f dot
write uh fd plus
and in this case we do want a new line
why can't i get away with that
uh okay
take that
fd plus uh oh we have to do like
literally a string
dummy oh my gosh okay let's redo this
[Laughter]
dude ah okay
that's i think that's what you call
brain fart anyway okay
so uh plus new line right okay so that
should produce our file for us and i
kind of
want to check it um
once we hit that let's go ahead and
break let me just rerun that and while
that's running
we'll continue working over here so
we're going to say substring is nothing
now 4 uh for split in
sd um
we're going to substring
um this is a toughy
shoot uh i think i do want to
ah dnr
data fd so we're going to do this we're
going to say fd up here okay
that doesn't change this and then here
we're gonna
split by um
i'll make this an f string
two of these new line characters
let's check our file now
okay so that looks good um so the next
thing we want to do is come over here
uh and so we split by new line character
and
character for splitting uh what we want
to check
now uh is we kind of want to like
substring
[Music]
let's print print the sub string
and then break uh because i i
can't remember like when you split by it
um
i think we retain it on the string but i
just want to check that
what the heck what are we looking at
here
we are looking at what are we looking at
why did this happen
print substring substring oh print split
dude my brain is just like apparently
not working again i think i gotta stop
like recording kind of in the mornings
so we do have
this would be a new line new line new
line why are we looking at
uh the fd ah
i knew fd
i think also it's just the live coding
like i just this is probably this is
pretty accurate i think
to realistic coding for me anyway
uh
there we go okay one thing we definitely
should have done
is uh some new lines
uh so let's go print
[Music]
print uh and then this should be the
break we want to see each of the splits
what i'm hoping to see is double new
line at the end
or beginning i guess
no yeah so it just goes away yeah
yeah so we need to add it to the end
right we need otherwise this would not
go very well
because we're actually going to re
rebuild it back together we're going to
build it back better
and hopefully be within our
range so what we want to do now then
is print split what we're going to say
now
is sub string plus
equals um
split plus
that
uh and then uh what we want to ask
is if uh we'll take this
might regret this hope not uh if len
substring is greater than the minimum
color length and is and actually we'll
say greater than equal
this one we care less about but whatever
is greater than the min car length
but is less than or equal to the maximum
character length
if that is the case what we would like
to do is we would like to go ahead and
write it
so we will f write boom
uh and substring
sub string plus new line and then
sub string equals
empty i think that's valid
uh we i guess we could continue to break
because we'll do this for one file
let's save that let's come over here
let's go ahead and run it
make sure that works and um
if that works uh we'll do the full file
and uh probably should have emptied this
out
though it looks like it worked it does
look like it worked
yeah so this was like a triple new line
here what is this code
what are we look what is this
someone comment below and tell me what
are we looking at here
what the heck
anyway um yeah it looks like it's
working i'm not sure i'm the biggest fan
of like this
obfuscated looking code um
but that is what it is i guess so so i
think we're ready to actually build this
file
so let's let's let's let it happen
um so we started with that 39 000 files
and the hope is that hopefully we will
wind up with
more samples than that so what i think
i'm going to do
i think i'm going to clear out this file
and python
so let's see what we get so hopefully
we'll have a training data set
um and hopefully it will learn this new
line character i it should i don't see
any reason why it wouldn't
are you really done we still must have
had a break
somewhere yeah we got well first off uh
f
right if for
uh let's get rid of this break here
uh and then we probably at some point
we'll hit a try and accept issue that
did not finish
um let's go ahead and just throw in a
try and accept before
we we hit it try
it accept exception as e print
string e otherwise we don't care
uh so we go ahead do that come over here
run that so we're just going to rerun it
hopefully it doesn't spit out again that
was kind of
it should have still continued i would
think but i guess we broke
the for loop there so okay
i'm just not buying it i'm not buying
what you're selling how big is this
is it really only 12 12
megabytes so all you're gonna give me
i mean the samples look okay uh the
problem i'm having is that's just like
way
from uh
like literally everything is starting
with imports so it's making me
not everything but almost every you know
imports or shebang
or
i mean here didn't at least so this is
at least
um
if not right so this straight split the
upstream
i feel like we're met we're screwing
something up here
uh but i'm not seeing like i would
expect that we would have
uh
more samples than that i mean this is an
except i mean it's enough data to train
with but i
feel like we should have more um
let me look this over and see if i catch
it but if i don't catch it i'll probably
just
move on
sd4 split in
sd yeah that's correct split
we add that to the sub string if it is
uh it's possible that um we want a
bigger range
i mean that i mean it could be that
we're just not getting exposed
we split i mean we're only splitting by
double new lines i mean we should be
able to
do that successfully but our window is
pretty small i mean maybe we want a
bigger window but i don't i don't i
really don't think that's our problem
um
whoops we don't want to do that uh we
want to
clean that file first let's try that one
more time
uh okay well that's going let's just
continue through reading through here
um sub string is empty
blah blah blah if the length of the
substring
[Music]
write it clear it
but then it should continue to iterate
uh it says it's already done again
i'm just not sure that's like legit that
it could
do it that first of all i don't think it
should be that quick but
also um
looks like it's i think that's the same
size isn't it that it was
oh maybe it's not i think the other one
was 12 huh okay so maybe that was our
problem maybe we just didn't allow it
um enough wiggle room but i still
well that's a different yeah from flask
i mean i guess this is i mean this looks
like it's working
but i would like to yeah i guess that's
two of them worked
but like what came next and why didn't
we get it
so many questions um
it might have been too long i mean i
guess that's what's going on i mean at
least now
we are seeing more way more examples of
not clearly the beginning of the text
and this is enough i think to to begin
to kind of train a model and just make
sure it kind of works like this should
give us
this should give us something it won't
be great because it's not
nearly enough data like you want it you
definitely want way more data than this
if i can find a decent way to host the
giant data set i will
but you can also pull it from github um
yeah okay so uh or do your own thing
like i just kind of assume that people
would want to do
maybe something else okay i think i'm
gonna stop it here
um in the next video uh we will
train the tokenizer so that's great
we've got everything on one line
but again you can't feed this
information through to a model
it's not going to know what to do with
this it needs to first be
tokenized or essentially converted into
text
or text taken take the text and convert
it into numerical form
um so that the machine can understand it
cause it has to it doesn't understand
text it's going to understand
tokens that represent text that map to
text maybe
but they have to be numerical form so
that's what we're going to be doing in
the next video is training a tokenizer
on this data
and then probably in that next video we
will train the model
and i'll train this little baby model uh
and we'll see kind of what results that
we get um but i will also
be sure to train the full-size model and
i'll show you guys that
the results to that and i can probably
share that model like i can share the
model that was trained
on the gigantic data set and again you
could take that
and then fine-tune it to some other
thing that you're trying to do and that
model i will
it'll be trained on this big boy machine
here and uh
it should be a halfway decent like it's
not going to be amazing we're not going
to
write serious code with it i'm sure um
but it will i suspect be much better
than whatever we come up with the 75 000
examples
um but anyway cool uh if anybody spots
an error in
in what we've built here let me know i i
think it was i think the issue was just
how
how big of a window we were allowing
also again i'll just
state again that probably the best
course of action will be
because it won't the tokenizer will make
tokens that
the nothing will be after it's been
tokenized nothing will be 512.
so what we probably want to do is
actually after we tokenize them we kind
of see
what it what how big or how long are the
things like what if they're only half as
long
well we could double the length here so
anyway
uh we might revisit that might not who
knows
anyway questions comments concerns uh
you know the deal leave them below
if you're interested in learning about
neural networks more
you should check out neural networks
from scratch the book by myself
and daniel you can check that out at
nnfs.io
otherwise i will see you guys in another
video
you